Eh, how many laps do you
have to ride?  Hey
, I think I should study here
Yes,
I have more power than everyone else, so I thought I could still do
it And actually, I'm the stupidest of my sisters, so everyone knows
I'm going to rest for today, and I spent all my
savings at the amusement park  No,
Mr. Uesugi doesn't
know How stupid you are Do
you know the reason why we transferred
schools?  It's a prestigious place, is
n't it?
Uesugi-san,
you get everything right.
Only 1 of the 4 failed.
And yet, after going to the hospital, he transferred to another school
.
But it's a salvation forest
At the same time, a big Kase The name of the place where it stops
[Music]
Please let me study even a little now
I don't want to drag everyone's legs
anymore I said I'm off today
I have nothing to do